hello everyone my name is Mattel alone
and I work in a Google Play apps and
games business development team welcome
in my day-to-day job I work with some of
the most successful apps and games
developers and I always think that
there's lots to be learned by apps
developers by looking at how successful
games developers are built what are the
key things that games developers care
about when they actually build their
gains for success in the next 30-40
minutes i'll try to answer that question
by showing you some of the key metrics
that they look at and now they go about
and optimize for them i will also try to
extrapolate some rules that you as app
developers can take in your day-to-day
job and hopefully use to optimize your
apps and also show you some examples of
how this learnings have been applied by
app developers successfully but before
before doing that I want to address the
elephant in the room right away apps and
games are not exactly the same actually
one key difference is that it's much
harder to make money on apps than it is
on games and for the purpose of this
talk the main difference here is that
gains enjoy much more flexibility when
it comes to monetizing that's because if
you think about it a game is a virtual
world where with virtual currency and
items so basically there are endless
possibilities in terms of what games
developers can put together as
monetization mechanics bundles and price
points while app developers have less
flexibility they're actually limited by
the services and the goods they are
trying to sell within their app and so
less flexibility less granularity but
there's also lots of common ground and
the main key thing in common is the
business model for most apps and games
the business model is a freemium model
and if you share that business model the
equation is here on the right should
always be true your cost per install
your CPI should always be lower than the
lifetime value of the users that you
bring in and lifetime value is a
function of retention engagement and
motivation
now in a world where there is a more
competition for user acquisition and
store visibility the CPI is actually
rising for everyone for both apps and
games and that means that to make this
equation work you really need to focus
on the right side of it the lifetime
value and those key metrics that drive
life the lifetime value and among this
really it all starts with retention
retention is king this data from mobile
intelligence company kwatra show you why
these are average retention curves of
apps on games on the left and apps on
the right they are ranked by daily
active users so you see the blue line
represent the top 10 apps in the world
by daily active users the red line is
top 50 yellow line top 100 and green
line is top five thousand you see how
better retention always rise better
performance and games developers know
this very well they actually before even
launching their game before investing in
user acquisition they spent a lot of
time and resources optimizing their game
for this key metric this process is
called soft launching they launched an
account in a few test markets or to a
beta community and they really spend
time tracking how this retention work
for their game and change their games to
the point where they're comfortable with
the retention curves they see when they
think that this retention can support
that lifeline value equation that I show
you before and so that they can actually
invest profitably in user acquisition
this process is very rigorous and it
requires a lot of attention but it
ensures that only the right the
resources are all invested in the right
products as a matter of fact lots of
games get killed in this process also I
disability one so actually some of them
never see the light just because they
don't have good retention if if you want
to measure recent retention you can do
so with firebase analytics you have a
retention reports that shows you not
only your retention curve on the top but
also your ascension stats stats by
courts of users that installed
your app in a given day so you can also
track how as you release new versions of
your app and people and install them how
retention change and up fully improves
as you optimize for attention all right
so lots of common ground retention is
king but i want to show share with you
three key rules that you can take from
games developers and hopefully use these
to optimize your apps the first one is
focusing on the engagement cliff what i
mean by engagement cliff is shown by the
same chart i showed you before from
petra the retention curves here they did
the thing that I didn't alight before if
you look at it that is that the biggest
drop in retention happens in this word
in the first seven days no matter how
successful the app is you see that
that's where retention really dropped
dramatically drop somatically after that
all curves tend to flatten so really the
apps that are doing a better job in
terms of retention are doing that in the
first seven days that's where you win
now depending on what type of app you
have your day seven average retention
can vary you see here on the right
average retention day seven retention
for different categories of app so you
it varies between forty percent for news
and magazines to fifteen percent for
photography but that means that between
sixty percent and eighty-five percent of
users are lost in those first seven days
so clearly lots of impact in addressing
those first seven days and that's
because user users downloads lots of app
download lots of apps and they try them
and during those first few experiences
they actually decide whether they want
to keep using them or otherwise they
forgot about them too sometimes i
uninstall them so really addressing that
specific experience that is between
learning about your app being
comfortable with it and deciding to
actually keep using it is the most
important part games know this very well
they actually face a very steep
engagement cliff which is you have to
learn how the game works
you have to learn new rules you have to
learn new mechanics you have to
understand why you should go through
this all these challenges you need to
care about it also and that that part of
the experience is normally the tutorial
games spend a lot of resources and time
optimizing the tutorial because they
know how critical it is I want to play a
video an extra love a video that we shot
with the pixel bury it was a very
successful game developer and it's
particularly good with their tutorials
they have more than 75 percent of users
that start one of their tutorial
tutorial actually complete them so let
me play the video here I know players
coming in we hit them with story right
away and we try and do it in a way where
it's a little more natural you know we
are cognizant that a lot of people
playing games on mobile phones may not
want to read too much text so we try to
ease players into that but by the time
they finish our tutorial we're hoping
that they're already caught up in the
lives of these characters and they want
to learn more about their backstories
and what's going on I think it is
important to give people kind of that
sense of progression in a game
especially in mobile games because I
think with a lot of games that you can
reach a certain point where you're just
repeating the same actions and you want
to feel like you're doing something
different I think story is a great way
of differentiating that and saying you
know oh now you're dealing with a new
villain or now you're dealing with a new
issue that's come up so they talk about
two key thing one is the story the story
for their game is the key element the
key value that you should care about
when you play this game and they want to
make sure that you start experiencing
the story from the first experience why
should the player care about this game
the second thing to talk about is
progression the sense of progression
that should always be present in games
and if you think about it this goes
beyond the tutorial is actually what a
game is it always presented with a new
challenge that challenge though
shouldn't be too challenging otherwise
you're frustrated and you live the game
but also it shouldn't be too easy as
wise your get bored and you also leave
the game and so games
think a lot about that and this is an
example of how they look at it play dots
another successful game developer built
this chart for their game called two
dots and the chart is lots of dots and
those dots are actually levels in the
game and those levels are mapped along
two variables one is the revenue per
player in that specific level and the
other one is the lapse rate in that
level so many people left the game in
that level this gives you an idea of our
frustrating and challenging the level is
and also our actually engaging and how
much people actually want to spend money
in that level by optimizing the
difficulty level of the levels sorry for
below the red line they actually managed
to improve not only conversion but also
average revenue per paying user so
progression is very important but this
is very specific to game so let's try to
extrapolate some learnings for apps
climbing the engagement cliff it's all
about recognizing that those first seven
days are very important and also quite
difficult for a user to go through them
there's lots of lots of things happening
and really the value of your app is not
clear to them yet so the first thing you
should focus on is finding that key
feature that without much engagement
provides value to the user something
that can give them a WoW is that or
something that can convince them that
they should stick around and it
shouldn't require too much for them to
actually unlock that so present that
straight away the second thing is
defining those activation moments those
things those steps in that engagement
cliff that you need the users to go the
user to go through it could be signing
in uploading something about themselves
adding some friends whatever key action
activation moment you need them to do to
fully unlock the value of your app and
start using it to its full potential
those are the activation moments you
should make sure at that point that
those are presented gradually with a
gradual invest also investment from a
user perspective so that the user is
not overwhelmed they feel this sense of
progression they're going in a direction
they understand whether you're asking
them to do these things and they're
actually gradually unlocking the value
of your app as part of that for example
if you're requiring them to sign in you
should treat that as a service you
should show them the value of doing that
before asking them to do it this is
again in that sense of progression that
unlocking that value showing them the
value first and then asking them to do
something also if you have paywalls
should carefully manage the appearance
of them in those first seven days again
the user doesn't really know exactly the
full value of your app yet you probably
don't want to overwhelm them and ask
them about also about pain until they're
fully comfortable with the app and if i
unlock this value you can optimize along
these lines using again fire business
analytics the funnel repartir can help
you in the final report you can create
any custom event that you want it could
be signing in uploading photo whatever
process activation moment you need the
user to go through can be defined in the
funnel read words and you can track how
many users start that process or task
and complete it so you can also put them
in in a sequence and see as a funnel
where the user gets stuck you can see
how many people started one action
second action the third action and
identify those roadblocks that stop them
from actually going through all of them
so very powerful tool and now I want to
show you a couple of examples of apps
that have implemented this rule
successfully in their app the first one
is OkCupid OkCupid is a dating app
dating apps are a great example of
engagement cliff because before you can
actually use a dating app you have to do
lots of things you have to sign in you
have to write something about yourself
you have to upload a photo of yourself
you have to answer some questions in
some case like in okcupid case and you
have to start liking people so lots of
things and okcupid recently redesigned
they're all onboarding experience to
make it more gradual and step-by-step
also they made each task more enjoyable
skippable and they provide a good
positive feedback to the user as they
went through these tasks again
announcing this sense of progression
that the user had to feel to actually
complete these tasks as a result they
got twenty one percent better day seven
retention this means that after seven
days they add twenty percent more users
same cost per install after seven days
they are twenty percent more users how
they did this this is how it look like
before the redesign so you see they're
asking you to write something about
yourself to upload a photo to answer
some questions and this is all
presenting a series of modal windows
with no clear sequencing also if you
start one of these activities for
example answering the question you see
here the questions you use here on the
right those are presented in a all
together not very does it look very fun
to go through all them quite actually
overwhelming this is how it looks after
the redesign the first and only thing
you need to care about one after you
sign in is answering those five
questions you have to answer one by one
and it's easy and nice to go through of
them you swipe right to say yes you
swipe left to say no once you have
completed this task then only then
you're asked to upload a photo you can
do it or skip it but that's the only
thing you need to care about and after
that you can start enjoying the app you
can browse and start make getting
familiar with it and you already have
done part of what you need to do to
actually be able to use it but also they
remind you of the other things that you
should do in order to fully unlock the
value in this case start liking five
people so that their algorithm can
better match you with people you might
like all right that wasn't one example
the other examples freeletics
freeletics is a fitness up and I think
that's probably the best example of an
engagement cliff when you download a
fitness app you're probably not doing
fitness yet so the fitness app needs to
convince you to go to the gym and
actually do fitness it's not enough if
you just download Yeah right so that's
the first key challenge the second
challenge is between you when you
download the app and you actually go to
the gym to use your app there might be
some time in between and what do you do
with the app and in those days then
you're not going to the gym you might
forget about it or you might find
another app right so how do you keep
users engaged in that time frame and
that's common to other verticals but
definitely Fitness is a good example of
that freeletics address these challenges
by making sure that they're onboarding
experience felt more personal from the
first minute you started your building
some key attainable goal that is
personalized based on your input and
that you feel more empowered to actually
go and cheap as a result they obtain 47
better day 1 retention so almost fifty
percent more users after the first day
kept using the app how they did that
this is our look before they redesign so
basically you download the app you get a
few cards of what the app does and right
after you are asked to sign in and after
signing in your asked top team in your
in their newsletter after that you're
considered I register user and you can
start browsing the app understanding
what it does for you and and taking next
steps basically what they did is
introducing this after those first few
cars that I show you the photos about
the app the thing they do is they ask
you are you a male or a female let's
start knowing understanding who you are
and once you answer that first question
they start personalizing the appearance
of the rest of the screen so if you're a
male you see male picture if you're
female using female picture and then
they ask you what's your fitness level
they also tell you why they're asking
you this it's because they're starting
to know you they're starting to learn
about what you care about
so they can build your first workout
experience clear value they're treating
this information as a service for you
and they're giving you a sense of
progression set third step is your
what's your goal do you want to lose
weight you want to build muscles what
why do you want to do fitness after that
only after that you're asked to sign in
now you understand the value of signing
in you're storing this information and
you're allowing them to build your
personal workout experience much more
different than just asking people to
sign in without knowing why I should
sign it right then they ask if you want
to join their newsletter but again you
understand why now they're gonna send
your personal recommendation based on
your goals to your inbox after that this
the last thing you see is a screen
feedback screen that tells you that
they're actually building your first
workout experience so again it's much
more compelling to go through the first
experience of this app even if you're
not a gym because you're you're doing
something in that direction there is a
progression toward that first gym
experience the other thing also after
this you feel that you have some gold
you and probably are more motivated to
actually go to the gym and do it and
actually this can be seen in the impact
that they had also on day three
retention which was seventeen percent
better than the previous version so even
after this first experience the people
were actually using the app more and
that's probably because they were more
motivated to go to gym and actually do
what you do with a fitness app which is
thickness alright that was on boarding
and hopefully at this point your users
are retained on boarded and they
understand the value of your app and you
want to monetize them the next two rules
are about that the first one embracing
your apps multiple personality disorder
this is what I mean by that this is a an
average revenue distribution curve for
an average game no matter how successful
a game is lots of people will not spend
a dime in it
and even among the ones that spend there
are very different amounts that they're
going to spend a big segment might spend
very little a small segment might spend
lots of money and then there are other
segments in between recognizing
understanding with what each user is
gonna potentially spend in your game and
how they like to spend what is the value
perception that they have what is their
propensity to spend and targeting them
based on what you know about them with
special custom in-app purchase offers
that's the key to achieve much better
conversion and revenue per user this is
an example of our game developer looks
at this this is woulda and it's just one
way to look at it they segment their
users along two variables one is
progression in the game and the other
one is spending level so for each
segment you see in blue they have
different way to target them different
offers that they can trigger to for that
specific segment for example if you're a
new player they offer you a starter pack
now if you buy this you become an early
spender you're not just a new player
you're someone who spends early and they
try to upsell with some other offer if
you buy that then you become an early
Eddie spender you're in a different
segment now and they might target you
with a different offer if you don't buy
you might become a mid spender so later
in the game they know what which steps
you took and they will target you with a
different discounted offer based on that
segment if you don't buy then you might
become a late spender so they will
target later even later in the game
which is even different offer that's a
very simple but very effective way to
look at it a more advanced and
complicated but very effective way is
this adder example from space shape what
they do is that they analyze their
players behavior in those first seven
days and they predict the lifetime value
that those users will bring to the game
for the rest of their life in the game
and they look at how they spend what
they spend on and also how they like to
spend
and then they target them with different
offers by doing this they achieve two
times better conversion than having a
one-size-fits-all approach this is how
it works players play for the first
seven days space a analyzes their
behavior their spending pattern and
based on their lifetime value models
they predict with how much the value
each user will bring to the game and how
they like to spend and they assign this
each user to a separate segment here you
see to an example two segments just to
give you an idea the first segment has
medium lifetime value but they actually
spend a lot only they spend in one go
and they're not very frequent buyers
they might not spend again or they will
spend but a later stage not very
frequently the second group they spend
less in a single instance but they're
more frequent they're going to spend
they're going to keep coming and
spending so there are their life and
value is higher it's just that they like
to spend in a different way this dude
segments will see different offers in
the game the first one will see a big
bundle with a very high price point lots
of value in it but that's the way to
convert this these people they're not
they're not scared about seeing a big
price point but they also want big more
value because they're not probably going
to come back and spend later and that's
what you should focus on as a developer
now the second segment will see a much
smaller segments the bundle sorry but
and that will make them comfortable and
they will probably convert with that but
also the developer knows that they will
probably come back and buy more so
overall their left hand value will be
higher okay let's generalize and
extrapolate some rules that you can take
as app developers you need to recognize
that users will have a very different
value per section of your app and no
matter how successful you are no matter
our relevant your app is they will have
a different propensity to spend
and also a different way to spend if you
can recognize that segment your user
base based on this and target them with
specific custom in-app purchase offers
then you can definitely achieve a much
better conversion and revenue per user
you can use again firebase to do that
first of all you can use firebase
analytics to build segments exactly the
1i show you before here we use it to
build a high lifetime value segment that
actually has a very small price single
price point but frequent purchase
behavior and a medium lifetime value
segment that has a high single sprite
price point but none not frequent spin
behavior this is all done with firebase
analytics using events and attributes
that you're the users have and based on
this you can track how they perform any
chart in firebase analytics will show
you these two different segments and now
they be aged so you can better site them
but now what you can do you can also
target them with different offers using
remote config in firebase the way it
works for example let's say you have you
sell a subscription your newspaper or
fitness up and you sell subscription for
the first segment the one with high
single spin points but not very frequent
you can build promotion for your annual
subscription these guys are comfortable
spending a lot but not they don't want
to be bother every month they will buy
an annual subscription probably so you
can have a narrowly discounted annual
subscription for them and for the other
group with a meet you with a higher life
and value but single price price point
lower you can have a discount on a
monthly subscription so the price point
will be lower but they're more
comfortable doing that and you can
target them with this offer again it's
very easy to do this with remote config
a couple of you don't need to code you
just need to go through the options and
it will be very easy
this works on in-app purchases for
virtual goods it also works for physical
goods so if you have an e-commerce app
for example this example applies to you
this is wish a very successful
e-commerce app and they basically show
in their screen to show products to
users that they think they might want to
buy and they also apply the same concept
they show less expensive items to users
that have shown less engagement maybe
they haven't bought anything yet they
started using the app or they just not a
damn much engage and once they see that
the users are more engaged they spend
maybe a couple of times they start
showing them more expensive products
again it proved this proves that it
works as a result they obtain ten
percent better conversion alright the
last rule is selling umbrellas where and
when it rains it's basically not only
about what you sell umbrellas but when
and where you sell them so the best way
to describe them to describe this
example is showing you what play dots
does they recently redesigned their old
in-app purchase flow and as a result of
ten ten percent better revenue per
active user so without changing the user
base they got ten percent better
revenues by just by redesigning along
this lines and I'll show you what I mean
here so first thing when you start a new
level you see how many boosters you have
available for it for you and they give
you a one button that you can use to
purchase whatever boxes or boosters you
need to finish that level so you don't
have to go in the store in the game and
buy what you think you might need they
prompt you to buy before you start the
level exactly what you need and they
show you what you already have similarly
when you die in a level in this case
you're running out of moves they show
you another call to action and says why
don't you buy those extra five moves
that you need to finish the game there
the level so you don't have to quit the
game go to this store in there in the
game and buy what you need you can buy
now without having to
the level that you're actually trying to
finish this my only doing this they got
six percent more paying users by just
adding this to call to actions the other
thing they did is they moved some items
that some in-game items that you can
purchase eggs in writing to the UI of
the game so you again you don't have to
quit the game you can buy them as you
play whenever you want with one tap
they're always there by doing that they
got five percent better average revenue
per user so really it's all about making
purchasing easy accessible but also
relevant positioning those in-app
purchase those products that you're
selling exactly where you think that the
user will need them and triggering Cole
to act calls to action when you think
that those are the most relevant so that
users are more compelled to actually
purchase the best example to show how
this work in an appt environment is
tomtom they last year they moved from a
premium model so you just had to pay for
the app to use the app to freemium and
in that transition they got two point
four more paying users and that's
because they thought very carefully
about their business model and they
really implemented very well especially
along the lines of the ruler described
you before this is how it looks it's
very similar to the game i showed you
before you have 75 kilometres to use the
app for free after that you have to
upgrade and upgrading means that you
basically buying what they used to sell
before as a premium app what they did is
that they position that a great button
in the UI of the app and it's always
there you no matter where you are it's
always one type of way you also see the
countdown of those kilometers that you
have three kilometers that you still
have so you also feel the urgency of a
grading if you're running out of
kilometers very easy very relevant the
other thing they did is they introduced
on call to a call to action where when
they thought you would need to agree the
most for example you start a new trip
and they know that
we'll run out of kilometers during that
trip they tell you why don't you upgrade
now instead of doing it while you're
driving you might not have a connection
so really they when you start an
activity that they know arm is more
likely to convert you they prompt you to
do it second of course they show you
that call to action when you're actually
running out of kilometers or you ran out
so those little thing actually add up
and they're the ones that are really
make a freemium model successful another
example bit more simple and it may be
more applicable in most cases it's a
subscription example if you sell
subscription normally with a
subscription you'll lock different
features and contents and yes you can
offer that in your app and you can have
a list of all the things that that
subscription unlocks but also showing
the content and the feature in the full
of the app that are behind the paywall
and prompting the user to upgrade when
they're actually trying to access those
is very impactful this is what booze
udah does is a language learning app and
their subscription basically unlocks
more content and more languages and they
started putting these calls to action
with the button to actually go into the
purchase flow when you're trying to
access that content in those languages
that are behind the paywall and you see
the result here thirty percent better
conversion with the premium content and
eighty-three percent better conversion
with the languages so very impactful
alright to wrap up the three rules we
talk about our climbing engagement cliff
which is all about focusing on those
seven days that after the users install
the app understanding that those are the
key moments where the user is still not
comfortable your app define the
activation moments you need them to go
through and making sure that those are
presented gradually in the experience in
the first seven days but they are not
overwhelmed they feel a sense of
progression they understand why they're
doing what they're doing and they
hopefully fool me a lot of the value of
your app so that they will might stick
around for much longer the second rule
is about embracing your apps multiple
personality disorder freemium model is
all about lots of users wanting
different things and I've
having different perception value
perception being able to segment them
understand what they want and target
them based on their segments will help
you improve your conversion in a much
more effective way than using a
one-size-fits-all approach the third
rule we talk about is selling umbrellas
where and when it rains which means that
it's not only about what you sell but
also how you sell it and it makes a big
difference making sure that the in-app
purchases are presented in an easy way
to access them always at least one or
two tap away from from purchasing and
also triggering those call to action
when you think those in-app purchases
are most relevant for the user that was
it thank you very much